what's this results results are in five
percent
five percent in oh hagman 53 liz cheney
44.
what source do you have right now ap
first results uh
shoot i'm seeing this uh central valley
politics central politics and i believe
it's from
new york times new york times
oh there we go there we go wyoming at
large
hageman
54 to liz cheney 45 with five four
percent estimated reporting let's get it
points here we go here we go baby why is
her name in that done
so done why does it say hagman braces
for wyoming why are they like
wait what do you mean we're getting a
hero out of lit well why are you is
chinese yeah why isn't it saying
breakfast they're calling it this
because the incumbent why don't they
she's in office right now no but i get
what he's saying
why doesn't it say wyoming voters choose
their representatives yeah right well
because they've got to run an angle so
the angle is is that liz cheney is their
great avatar and she's being destroyed
by this this you know you know upstart
grassroots mega republican this is
shocking
grable with 59
it's a democrat i have no idea who that
is yeah
so i'd be interesting to see if they
have uh
details okay so only only a little bit's
in so far i saw the tweet
3486 so far for hagerman liz cheney with
296
i i almost can't believe it to be honest
and then you've got news there's not
gonna be a lot of them the good news is
that's chinese best district
is it i'm just kidding
no it's not large
right yeah at large yeah oh that's right
it's the whole state yeah there's
there's there's one district yeah it's
no district but i'm talking about the
precincts that are reporting oh really
yeah shout out to anthony
county it's casper so that's casper you
and i imagine cheyenne would probably be
her best yep yup cheyenne is pro
it's already looking good if outside of
cheyenne
huge early lead for hagerman huge
it's like a thou it's like not it's not
even a thousand it's five hundred
it's almost a ten point lead so the
votes just closed when do you think
they're tabulating it's coming in now
what do you think like three days until
the total count no well yes you know no
now we have because it's not wrong it's
not election day anymore it's now it's
election week and then it's election
months
some time to calculate
we're going to wait for the mail in
balance to get in yes and count them
next and then 3 a.m rolls around so but
technically it should be done by 2 3 a.m
right isn't that the way these votes
well i still love technically 8 pm and
they're yeah sooner than that
france france has it done in like five
hours yeah not even the whole country
yeah and 66 million votes something like
that i still love the uh was it the la
county with with the the signatures have
you seen this
that they oh yeah
that guy's gone they struck 200 000
signatures from his petition which just
coincidentally happened to be the put
him right under the threshold for a
recall well so here's the thing
something like 80 or 90 000 were not
registered voters and that should be
very easy to actually verify right so
they they they a bunch were like um not
registered voters or duplicates they
argued the bulk i think were duplicates
and unregistered voters that's like
two-sevenths i mean that's like
20
what percent that's like 38 of the
freaking votes came in where were
nullified if you extrapolate that out
signatures though so this is this is a
different thing
you get a petition you walk around you
go hey wanna sign a petition they say
sure they sign it they fill out their
information
i think 200 000 is a lot it's a lot of
relative votes there were only 760 000
tallied and 200 of them were were not
accepted i mean if you so we call the
united states government if there's a
big election you get 50 150 million
votes these aren't votes these aren't
votes okay there's a difference between
someone going to a polling place being
handed a vote with their name on it
filling it out and then handing it to a
precinct you know a captain or whatever
that puts it in the box and certifies it
and someone on the street walking up and
saying sign this
so i can understand that signatures
would get disqualified but i'm saying we
can check this one easily
decision desk is calling it no what's
how yeah
it says right here how long decision i'm
right here
so why so early okay go to decision desk
because they're i would love
love love love to call it right now um
decision desk is calling it
ladies and gentlemen decision desk hq
projects harriet hageman is the winner
of the republican nomination for
wyoming's at large u.s house
congressional district she has defeated
rep liz cheney decision made 9 27 p.m
so what's the thug life jack with the
extremism symbol what's the what's the
value of decision
is decision desk like notoriously
accurate
it's yeah this is uh like
typically the most accurate the official
source
decision desk comes out and says it and
people usually roll of it this is the
verified decision desk saying it right
there you heard it ladies and gentlemen
oh yeah you just went to rome i heard
something jack just went to the vatican
i got a tweet
i got a tweet we're tweeting yeah let's
go chain you down
chaney down
god is good whenever i see a picture of
her she looks really upset really really
miserable sad like she's frowning looks
unhappy dynasty down yes the end of a
dynasty
too early to celebrate
well i'm just thinking we're talking
about elections and how long it takes
and validating signatures and things
like that and you know we just had a
primary here in maryland and they give
in maryland 10 days for mail-in ballots
to to be received and counted so we had
an election day and they counted the uh
walk-in early voting because you have
early voting and those get counted in a
batch so you get those results sometime
that evening and then they count people
who voted in person on that day and you
got those late in the day and then you
have to wait for the counts of the
mail-in ballots which
they do two or three days later and then
any ballots that come in later they get
counted the following week and then
provisional ballots okay let's just
let's let's just accept that right now
dave wasserman and cook political
reports are confirming
that that's great so so you know i get
it i get it but let us let us have
or they might have been doing some
polling yeah yeah
exit polls
and then this there's they may have
access to data that hasn't been
published yet like the ap reporters get
access to stuff they so they probably
have seen
updated just come in and with with with
casper the precinct that they already
have they're probably like yep that's
completely in line with what we have
there's no possibilities cheney's going
to win if if she's down 10 right away
i didn't even know who she was who was
that you said politicals also got it
coke political report so dave dave
wasserman he's he's kind of famous i
mean he's kind of a glorified refresher
as richard you've had if you haven't had
richard barras on you got to get him on
i just he's fantastic um i love rachel i
can't believe they called it so quickly
this guy's a glorified refresher but he
does the whole like i've seen enough you
know right right
yeah so if decision desk and cook
political are saying it it would be very
insane if they reversed that decision
later on yeah those guys they're they're
generally pretty conservative with this
actually yeah yeah yeah an election
wizard shout out to election wizard he
got called it actually before both of
them he's known for being a little bit
ahead of the grain on this i'd like to
uh give a round of applause to everybody
i think liz cheney is just so awful and
um
democrats should be cheering this right
right right all the left rachel maddow
everyone who was against iraq
i bet they're all tweeting like this is
the end of america it was funny there's
a tweet from one democrat guy and he was
like if liz cheney loses her primary
it's the end of the republican party and
it's like no one believes you care about
the republican party i want to save it
like if anything everyone assumes the
opposite of what you say is true
liz cheney
you're fired
now we gotta look we gotta look to
alaska
yup yeah that'll be well they're they're
in totally different times right so i
think that'll be a while that's today
yeah alaska alaska's today
now because alaska has a runoff included
in in addition to the rank choice so
they're saying that it's that um if
neither get 50
then it goes to the top the top two to
go to a runoff that'll be murkowski and
chewbacca most likely i want to see the
ranked choice tallies if if possible
from the alaska thing because i don't
just want to see what the final answer
was i want to see the process of how it
got to whoever is going to win on that
because i'm really fascinated with
ranked choice voting i think there's a
future it is interesting
andrew kloster liz chaney just collapsed
faster than kabul wow
i mean it's it's i can't believe they
called it i was like we got five percent
we're gonna yeah yeah it's like it's
gonna be three days before they call it
and it was five minutes okay it was 20
minutes 27 minutes but still
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there